there's a lot of guys right now today
walking around that are basically
estrogen dominant meaning they've got
way too much estrogen not enough
testosterone and some of it is a
function of conversion from testosterone
to estrogen and a lot of it of course
comes from environmental factors um
let's just go write down a list you know
like real real quick here so we're
talking things like uh toiletries uh
perfumes water bottles water bottles uh
sunscreens anything with like like
sunscreen with like benzone on it like
like oxybenzones or anything that ends
in zone benzone or anything like that
those are all estrogenic compounds
there's a lot of estrogenic compounds in
different kinds of foods foods you know
food packaging soy is you know
estrogenic a lot of guys will argue on
that one but just read dr anthony's
research book he's got all the data
there you can figure out for yourself
anything i miss there uh melissa or
jordan when it comes to estrogen
metabolism and why it's important for
guys to consider so when guys
are carrying too much that or they have
too much estrogen in their blood and
their bodies just it's converting too
much testosterone over to estrogen
you'll see a certain like profile on
people like
you know i was uh i was just traveling
and one of the hotels i was in they had
this like epic beach shot of venice
beach from like the 70s and all you saw
were like thin people
yeah and now what you see is even in
like younger boys these sort of like man
boobs or gyno mastica like purdue
yeah yeah if you're a pear-shaped you
have too much estrogen and
i think the big picture here as well is
eliminating your environmental exposure
to estrogen we have control over some
aspects and we don't have control over
others
but something that we have huge control
over is our body fat percentage and we
see what ends up happening is with a
high body fat percentage even dht gets
converted an aromatase over to estrogen
so i think a huge consideration like i i
can't wait to talk about dim
also calcium or calcium de-glucorate so
your alpha cdg product is also a great
estrogen metabolizer but for any of the
men on the call right now if you know
and you know if your body fat is an
optimal um if you carry fat in your
thighs and you carry you know fat in
your mid mid section thighs and lower
body
you want to start affecting that too so
that's something that we have control
over
and um dim and i'm not going to try to
pronounce dinner doll of methyl totally
pronounced no it's dimethyl tryptophan
that's something different but yeah
thank you um no that's emt but yeah yeah
like dim itself is um something that my
trt doctor recommended to me years ago
when i first started um it did
effectively lower my estrogen panel
along with a few other supplements that
i've got here as well
it's it's a useful product it does work
can you talk about specifically why
melissa yeah absolutely so one of the
main mechanisms when it comes to dim is
it helps to maintain a really good ratio
of what we consider sort of your your
beneficial or good estrogen and lowering
uh some of your bad estrogen so it's
your your two hydroxy and your 16
hydroxy estrogen that it creates a
beneficial balance between that um
what's really great is dim you can find
it in cruciferous vegetables so your
cauliflower and your broccoli but yeah
you're not gonna get enough yeah
absolutely so i mean including some of
these foods is is great but we're
talking about a potent dose of zinc part
of me of dim and something that we've
done a little bit differently that you
now have available in your line is we've
done a dim that's suspended in a liquid
so specifically in mct oil and vitamin e
solution so there's certain nutrients
that are really difficult to absorb and
we've touched on some of that and dim's
definitely one of them it's this weird
crystalline structure so what's happened
here is with the suspension of the mct
oil and the vitamin e you're getting a
really absorbable dip so you're seeing
it at 100 milligrams and the reason that
you're able to take just that 100
milligrams and have it go further is of
course you're getting better
bioavailability so that's just you know
fancy terminology for your body's
ability to
to absorb it dim also acts as an
aromatase inhibitor so i think you know
i just briefly mentioned that sometimes
you can especially if you're on trt
you're more susceptible to converting
some of that test over to estrogen um so
using something like dim can actually
help with um the aromatase activity as
well
yeah because i think what most people
don't realize and i'm sure there's going
to be somebody here who's higher level
of um
biology than i than i have but you don't
actually produce estrogen you produce
testosterone and it converts into
estrogen right so a lot of guys who take
trt or do these hyper dosages like you
can even see in phil heath recently he's
starting to get a little bit of the man
boobs because he's taking all this
testosterone and still converting into
too much estrogen
so i know you recommend a lot of your uh
to a lot of people like in the one
percent group or in your book you even
talk about trt
and melissa maybe you can talk about
this because i know you worked with a
lot of bodybuilders but
especially if you're on trt the doctors
i know that prescribe it they go a
little bit higher with them than
somebody who might not be on trt so they
might go up to like three or four
capsules a day if you're if you're
supplementing with testosterone versus
maybe one or two capsules a day if
somebody's not taking trt yeah and i'll
say this like from my own experience
because i mean
when you go on therapeutic dosages of
testosterone you will make more estrogen
like it will go up
and you can either control it by
lowering your dose
increasing the frequency of your
injections
or the doctor may sometimes want to put
you on an ai which just means is going
to put you on a aromatized inhibitor
which is going to
slow down it's not going to stop it's
going to slow down the conversion of
testosterone and estrogen the problem
with ais is they're expensive and you're
introducing another pharmaceutical
chemical in your body that you really
don't need if you manage things properly
with more natural stuff i mean you could
eat you eat a lot of broccoli and
cauliflower and kale and get and get dim
from that source you can bite honestly
guys you buy dim from any you know
natural store that you want like i'm not
saying buy this product but i am saying
buy this product if you watch my channel
basically because it's a good product
and i've used it and they ship it
properly like again here i'm going to go
full well the liquid the liquid dim is
really important so like when melissa
well it is liquid in a gel cap right
that's the size of the bottle and it's
basically like gel capsules in there
i've seen other dim products which come
in hard capsules and i've seen other
ones that come in that um dissolvable
capsule where they put the powder inside
but the liquid form is always the most
absorbable if i'm not mistaken right
liquid tends to be the best and it
depends especially with this because
it's more of a fat based nutrient oh and
and we also do
oil um vitamin e and sunflower less than
yeah so
um suspending it in that liquid it's
it's like a carrier it's like it's an
easier way to carry oil yeah exactly and
um
like personally
when i like i i so i did some genetic
testing as well as like just my regular
functional tests and unfortunately for
me i have a hard time detoxing estrogen
and i aromatase really quickly yeah so i
always grew up with a little bit of a
bigger chest or that pear-shaped body
that melissa was talking about and it
didn't matter like how much i worked out
or or what i was doing it just it
wouldn't go away
when i started taking um i i personally
went on trt just because of the head
trauma i used to have
this
really worked in conjunction with um
zinc and calcium diglucrate to keep my
estrogen levels or my estrone like in
check versus going crazy because if i
would someone like me was genetically
prone to like turning it into estrogen
if i don't have these things in place
like
i could take all the trt i want i'm just
going to look worse and worse actually
right
and i put in the ticker below guys um
the website and i'll put a link and pin
in the top comment after the show
renders and it's not but if you
use coupon alpha 10 you get 10 off the
listed price here so who should be
taking dim specifically you're saying
pretty much anybody like a pear-shaped
body they're carrying a lot more body
fat around their legs their ass their
like waste and all that
my opinion might be a little extreme but
with it depends where you live if you
live in a city
so like if you think about all the
toxins that everyone's exposed to on a
daily basis living in a city
and the other thing people don't realize
when you drink tap water
yeah there's estrogen in that too yeah
it doesn't get rid of all the birth
control so like you're you have all
these women on birth control now uh it's
in your water so
there's a lot of functional medicine
doctors and um
like people that i respect in this space
that think almost everybody should go
through either dim all the time or cycle
it a few times a year
i mean if you want to be like truthfully
sure get your blood labs pulled and when
they pull them have them check your
estrogen levels and if they're at the
top of the reference range you're
estrogen dominant you'll probably get
some sort of benefit you know with
lowering that and getting rid of some of
that body fat
and then again there's different sites
so like as melissa said your thighs your
legs like men are normally not getting
um
what's it called on the back of your leg
there cellulite cellulite the cottage
cheese like dimples exactly but if you
have cellulite as a man that could be
that's a very huge huge sign that you
probably have too much estrogen uh we
always talk about man boobs if you have
if you carry weight in your chest that's
a sign um love handles like things when
you think about that typical like you
talk about the golden ratios so if your
body's not a v-shaped golden ratio and
you're looking more pear-shaped or more
like the female golden ratio like your
your waist is thinner than your hips
yeah that could be a sign that you
probably have a little bit too much
estrogen all right
um let's go to the fat burn category and
before we do that richard can we also
just do um cdg in with estrogen
metabolism yeah is that under
performance or testosterone support um
you know what let's go to the main shop
right there no no it's right there
that's the dk no that's dk you want cdg
right we want cdg and also zinc is
really important for okay here let me
we'll scroll down this way uh cdg was
this one here so let's talk about that
so cds now that we're yeah now that
we're on the conversation calcium
yeah
yeah so we we discussed how we have
ratios of estrogen at different forms of
estrogen and and how we want to optimize
that calcium diglucrat has a bit of a
different mechanism of action um it
essentially works predominantly in the
gut it was actually jordan that gave me
this really great analogy where just if
you think of taking calcium de-glucoid
it's like you take your garbage out you
put it in garbage bags and you leave it
in the side of your house and then
you've got like [ __ ] raccoons that go
in and and take the garbage out of the
garbage bags and like you know that's
annoying then you got to go and clean it
back up again so unfortunately what ends
up happening is um for some of us we can
properly remove the estrogen however if
we have gut issues we're getting we're
having those toxins reabsorb and um
we're getting ourselves into a world of
hurt because it we're working in the gut
level here with the cdg so by adding the
additional calcium d blue grit um and
essentially it's working in the in the
gi tract calcium people create it's
metabolized into three different
compounds
it helps you eliminate estrogen and help
you properly excrete it from the body it
as well as other steroid compounds
specifically with phase two liver
detoxification so if you have issues
with liver function if you're working to
optimize your liver you have some gut
issues you're going to want to use the
dim the alpha dim in conjunction with
the alpha cdg yeah and i think we need
to clear this product up on the label
because people look at it and they're
going to see 150 milligrams of calcium
and then 1.2 grams of calcium
degluterate so there's only in two
capsules there's actually only 150
milligrams of calcium like when you
think of the mineral calcium
um that's majority calcium deglucorate
and with that you're getting 600
milligrams per capsule or 1.2 grams for
two caps and yeah to melissa's point so
the reference is like let's say you take
dim to help you bring the garbage out
while you're bringing the garbage out
the raccoons are ripping the bag open so
what d glucorate does it almost acts as
like a double or a triple bag so it
stops the garbage from like leaking out
while you're walking to to put on that
curb and that that was given to me by uh
by ricky breyer as a functional medicine
doctor actually got it
um quick question because this came up
and i don't want to skip over it but um
we're shipping only to the us right now
yeah supplement laws are very different
depending on where you go so in the
meantime yes we're only shipping to the
us but i do know there's a lot of people
who can ship to an address in the states
and they'll ship po box yeah they'll
ship to
south america like we have people that
we know who are in colombia or elsewhere
that will ship to florida and then from
florida get shipped out yeah we talked
about you know expanding this to canada
and different places in the world later
on i mean this is more of just uh okay
let's get this started let's get it
tested and make sure that you know the
products loved and it and the shipping
works and everything like that so
um let me put this back up in the stream
and apparently argentina is a fun place
to be though i heard yeah
um
what other products are tied into
estrogen metabolism that we might want
to cover zinc as well yeah
we were jumping around here a little bit
but that's okay so we got zinc and this
is not just zinc this is a well
take it away melissa because it's got a
bunch of items in this product
yeah so one of the things that we like
to do when we formulate a specific
mineral let's say
especially zinc if you've ever taken a
multivitamin and had an upset stomach it
might be because a the zinc is a shitty
form of zinc and also zinc requires a
lot of stomach acid for you to properly
absorb it so what we've done is we've
included zinc but then all of the other
cofactors like vitamin b2 b6
molybdenum
taurine and malic acid so everything
that you need to really absorb zinc
properly
so i think we we all know that zinc is
going to be hugely helpful when it comes
to optimizing testosterone but it also
does have anti-aromatase action so
very helpful there and when we talked
about body fat uh zinc is really great
at helping to regulate blood sugar
levels so we're using this it for so
many reasons it's also um immune right
now which i know a lot of people are
really focused on yeah zinc is really
important for immunity along with
vitamin d
yeah
one thing i'm noticing
i work with quite a lot of professional
teams and
they used to sort of use zinc but not
really but now since you know the
pandemic and everything they're starting
to really stock up and get all their
players to take this as like a standard
everyday thing
okay so so there's that um so before we
go from there though rich there's
something i want to mention um and this
sort of got to the beginning we were
talking about you're not what you take
or what you absorb so what people don't
often realize they think when you take
zinc that every zinc is identical but if
you look at this one it says zinc this
glycinate chelate
um
so
if i was just to give you like a raw
material zinc your body wouldn't know
what to do with it so we have to do
something called chelating
which comes from the greek word kilos or
like to claw and we have to attach it to
an amino acid or to a salt so your body
knows what to do
and that's very important because some
amino acids or salts absorb better than
others so when we use bisque glycinate
and a lot of people know what magnesium
glycinate is now it got really popular
it's attached to the glycine molecule so
it's actually
bis glycinate two um
glycine molecules to one zinc
and the absorption of this is
actually like the stats change but on
average two times better than like what
the old form of zinc used to be which
was zinc citrate or zinc carbonate or
something like that um so this allows
most people to take just one pill of our
zinc and get everything that they need
so it is a dose of the 30 ml because it
looks like it's about 30 milligrams yeah
like is that is that a true 30
milligrams or is it like you know you're
like you're getting more than that
because the way that it's it's
structured
all these other supplements it's it's an
elemental level of 30 milligrams so
you're getting 30 but on average when
you have a bisque glycinate and this is
honestly one of the best forms you're
absorbing between 40 and 50 percent okay
some of the other forms you only get 22.
so iv's number one if you inject your
you know if you go get an iv um like a
vitamin cocktail yeah and then zinc
glycinates pretty much the highest
absorbed form of zinc that you can find
right but i mean there's certain like
supplements you don't want to throw in
an eye like like they're painful like i
know uh
yeah like i heard uh uh citrulline is
quite painful to attract her to take no
you don't want to do that or people do
carnitine shots like in fat sites and
that's really painful yeah yeah yeah um
let me just so you guys are getting the
notion that that they know exactly what
they're talking about i mean like we can
really geek out at a deep level here
with all this sort of stuff but um just
a quick super chat here from some
content says that address is five
minutes close to where i live
and he's up on a 720 good choice
five minutes with any car or that car
yeah no i guess he's talking about the
address here no i know i know i'm saying
here with this car maybe it's only three
minutes away um all right let me go back
here and
so here i'm here i'm going to try to
stick with the category so let's deal
with
the burn product
which is a fat burner and i'm gonna try
to zoom in on this a little bit more so
there we go so you can see it on the
full screen so talk about all of these
ingredients on
the alpha burn product that's the size
of the bottle there it's a much larger
bottle so we're talking three capsules
per serving yeah three capsules per
serving is for most people and then that
bottle is actually a two-month supply of
that okay
this is your fat loss multi um it's it's
basically a multivitamin is that what it
is
it's formulated as a multivitamin that's
going to help to support insulin
sensitivity and glucose metabolism so
especially when we're dealing with
excess body fat we can start to
intervene from a nutritional perspective
by obviously you know upping protein
trying to either cycle or reduce
carbohydrates and what this product is
doing is it's helping you break down and
metabolize your carbs and it's improving
your insulin sensitivity so we know that
this is going to be directly related to
things even like cortisol and when
cortisol goes up testosterone goes down
um so this is a product that's going to
help in so many aspects but first and
foremost helping you metabolize carbs
improve insulin sensitivity and help
with fat loss um
and one thing to mention and my mentor
charles poliquin taught me this one
if you are insulin resistant as a man
you're actually going to end up having
less testosterone and more estrogen so
you know one of the ways you could take
you could do everything else trt take
the estrogen detoxifiers but if you
improve your insulin sensitivity which
means how sensitive you are to insulin
um if you're insulin resistance you're
on the path to being diabetic
and
i just read a stat somewhere i think
it's something like 80 percent of people
in north america now are leaning toward
it towards insulin's resistance which i
know sounds extreme
um but
most people like paul saladino's book i
believe yeah i think it's in paul
saldino's book
um
so
taking this actually also plays into the
whole testosterone picture that we were
talking about because if you improve
your insulin and that's why a lot of
people go keto and their testosterone
goes up or go carnivore and their
testosterone goes up is there improving
their insulin resistance or sensitivity
you